if you think about how ludicrous it is
that there's a 2D image in front of you
that you can put your hand on that you
can look around the side of a monitor
and it's clearly not real but it's
enough to trick our ancestral mating
systems into thinking sex is about to
happen enough to arouse us so of course
your psychology is going to be lined up
with that sex is available I am now
aroused I want the sex I don't want to
entertain a long-term relationship with
an extended quoting process before I
have it
I absolutely love your writing man your
Psychology today articles are fantastic
congratulations oh brilliant and am I
right in thinking um I'm the first Welsh
person you've had on your show I've
heard that that was the rumor oh that
would be a very interesting start I
don't know
um sometimes people are like secret
Welsh secret welshies you know yes yeah
I'll have to just
let's just transition that to a ruggedly
handsome Welsh film sure yep I'm sure
that's a complete win as far as I'm
concerned and also the first openly
Welsh person we can definitely take that
you didn't used to identify as well
should now identify as something else
you're openly well yeah
I don't think the identity politics has
hit uh Welsh identity yet uh it's coming
for you soon Hold On Tight uh so you
just wrote this great article explaining
five evolutionary theories that everyone
should know to understand how
relationships work yeah evolutionary
mismatch what's that
so evolutionary mismatches this idea
that
um our psychology evolved
um you know and has remained relatively
stable over the last hundred thousand
years so it's this idea that Society has
moved quicker than our biology has been
able to cope with it so for most modern
problems we're approaching them with a
stone age brain
um and yeah it's something which in my
uh my teaching at Swansea I try to apply
that quite a bit to mating because a lot
of stuff that we have in the in the
modern environment is just something
that
um it makes more sense when you sort of
figure out that your brain is trying to
cope with it
rather than being able to master it
because it's such a novel novel thing
that it's not used to what would be an
example of that
so I think a really good the best
example of that is just sheer Choice
overload right so if you think about uh
ancestral human populations there's some
debate over the number but
um you know Dunbar bars number is like
150 people
um nowadays we have access to almost
limited Limitless numbers of people
um it leads to a lot more superficial
relationships
um when I and I mean like friends and
family
uh but also when you go online onto
dating websites it looks like there's
this unlimited pool of potential options
um and that leads to all sorts of crazy
things like
um people having to use sort of one
characteristic to narrow down the
playing field so dating I I think has
become a lot more univariate rather than
multivariate so historically you'd meet
up with somewhere and you see the whole
person you're taking their physical
attractiveness you also take in other
things about them
um and nowadays we don't even get to
that point where we can make a holistic
judgment because we're doing things like
oh they're not six foot so uh that
that's it they're off the radar
um I always like to it's really
interesting actually so some of some of
the research that I've done with um uh
Peter jonason has actually shown how
people then kind of compensate with that
because we have we're going to publish
this stuff on height but if you get the
the dating website data it's really
interesting and you plot up what what
guys Heights are you get this really
weird distribution where it's a normal
distribution until you hit 5 10 5 11 and
6 foot in which case it drops on all of
those and then suddenly you get this big
influx of everyone saying they're six
foot
um and embarrassingly I was one of those
Liars right so I met my wife on an
online dating website now I always tell
people I'm six foot minus one
um so I put that I was six foot on this
dating website and that got me past the
bar and now I'm happily married would
you or would your partner have not seen
you had you have put 511
no no way absolutely not absolutely
you're a victory Story You're a victory
so there we go you know so it's it it's
something that that people do but it
just kind of proves that that people
have and especially women so Steve and I
ran this study once that was uh a failed
study so we were go we were using Plenty
of Fish and we I know we're still
talking about evolutionary mismatch it
doesn't feel like it but we are
um and we set up some fake profiles on
Plenty of Fish with the idea that we
were going to manipulate status and job
role and see who got attention and who
didn't and we had to call off the
experiment after a week because we
balance the profiles nicely but the
female profile uh or the couple of
female profiles got like a thousand
messages in two days of guys going hey
hey hey hey
whereas the guys didn't get any messages
at all so we had no variance in the guys
to be able to carry on the study with
and this was back in like you know
probably 2009 2010.
um and so you know women are getting
inundated with with messages off of guys
quite superficial Ones playing playing
the sort of short-term game and so
naturally that means a narrowing down a
quick narrowing down of people using
very superficial criteria
um now from a mismatch perspective
that's crazy right the because
ancestrally your options would be like
two or three people in your village and
maybe guys from neighboring Villages
um so the disparity is is massive
what people are doing is creating
sometimes arbitrary uh at least to their
uh forebrain it seems to make sense
rules that can help them to narrow down
the degrees of choice that they have if
you only date within one particular race
if you only date within one particular
education exactly if you date within one
particular type of profession oh I I
just I need to have a doctor I think I
saw the other day that uh female doctors
one in five female doctors also date
another doctor or surgeon why yeah why
yeah I mean you've got a lot to bond
over but you would have presumed so all
of these things could just be a
cope for The evolutionary mismatch of
having a significantly broader Choice
option the same way as people elect to
do intermittent fasting as a way to deal
with the evolutionary mismatch of a
prevalence of salty sweets and sugary
Foods yeah so there's
exactly so there's the the narrowing
down element there's also like the
archaic preferences because the
preferences are functional right so
having having a partner who has some
status and has some resources that's
that's not a
um uh you know that that's a functional
thing
um where the mismatch comes in is that
now nowadays you don't necessarily need
that you know your welfare and your your
uh your flourishing doesn't depend for a
lot of people especially in Western
societies with good social welfare
programs it doesn't it doesn't depend on
another person as much as it used to but
you can't just turn the preferences off
in the same ways you can't just turn
jealousy off just because everyone's
using contraception you know it's no
longer jealousy some kind argue is no
longer functional now that we have
contraception but you can't just turn it
off but the narrowing thing I mean I I
think women get a bit of a hard time
sometimes for the for the for the
narrowing thing
um whereas for me it's kind of just like
a a competent heuristic that people use
whenever they've they've got too much
decision making to do so or too many
decisions to make you know this is why
people gravitate towards like ratings on
Amazon to cut down decision making
um hell you know you go to a supermarket
these days you go to a supermarket or
you want to buy some baked beans you go
to the big bean aisle whether it's then
25 different varieties and you pause and
you're like oh you know what's the
prices by the size this is why I like
shopping in lidl's and ALDI you want the
big beans they got there or you don't
it's a more simplified situation you
know so we've got all of these different
sort of very very modern factors
influencing
um our mating decisions which is why my
advice on the on the blogs is is to
maybe look to the Past a little bit
what do you mean so when I say look to
the past I mean how were people starting
relationships in the past I mean when
you get up the graph showing how people
meet one another I show this to to my
students all the time you know it's the
death of everything apart from you know
meeting in clubs and meeting online
meeting online is shot up it's doubt
something silly like 60 70 of people who
get married are meeting online the stuff
that's fallen off meeting through family
meeting through close Friends Meeting
through social groups meeting through
work all of these things are dropping
off and online's going up
um now the problem is all of those
things that are dropping down involve
other people that know you in some way
and so you know you're not meeting
people with this anonymity they can
ghost they can go away if they go if
they do something nasty to you there's
no social consequence if your social
lives aren't entwined in some way
um and sometimes the people who are
around us they know us best because
sometimes we think we know what we want
when we don't know what we want or
sometimes we think we know what's good
for us when we don't know what's good
for us
so you know sometimes I'm they're like
you know if you're really getting stuck
why don't you ask your friends to set
you up with someone why don't you ask
your parents what they think
um yeah so that's kind of just I'm not
saying it's perfect
um but it could be something to try it's
certainly a
untapped
uh pool given that most people now are
meeting their Partners online what that
means is that any strategy which isn't
meeting your partner online has a
competitive Advantage as a byproduct of
that okay next one error management
what's that
so error management is this idea that
for every choice you make
um you can air in one of two ways so you
can either make a false positive or you
can make a false negative so a false
positive is you know I see a small black
thing in the corner of my eye and I jump
thinking it's a spider but it's not a
spider right so I've made that error the
other side of the the false negative is
there's a spider there I don't notice it
right and let's just assume it's a nasty
spider that could do be harm not that we
get many of those in the UK so there's
two different types of error for for
decisions like that but they come with
different costs so the cost of of seeing
the spot what I think is a spider
reacting a little bit and then realizing
I'm okay what's that cost me a little
bit of cortisol and and uh you know
sympathetic nervous system activation
for a couple of seconds not much right
but if I don't see the spider
and it's a poisonous one and it's
creeping up then the consequences could
be could be more dire so error
management theory is
um this this idea that we evolve towards
making the errors which are least costly
for us so the reason why you get a lot
of people who are quite reactive to such
things is it's better to react to for uh
for a little cost for that error than
not react and have a big Associated cost
how does that relate to dating
probably the easiest one to relate it to
is the sexual over perception bias
uh so what you actually find in guys is
that they are more likely to perceive
sexual interest from uh women when it's
not there so the cashier the supermarket
smiles and instead of them being
friendly it's oh she's into me yeah and
if you stop and think about like what
the error is there so the error is if
I'm completely oblivious to that then
that's a Miss sexual opportunity
potentially yeah
um obviously you've got to go and take
some dates first and
etc etc but if she's genuinely
interested you don't want to miss out on
that opportunity because that's an
opportunity uh to potentially reproduce
um whereas if you see it when it's not
there and make an advance and this is
where it gets a little bit you know a
little bit tough from from a selfish
perspective the costs are quite limited
right so I get a little bit of rejection
yeah so from an evolutionary perspective
that's not the end of the world that's
not to say of course there aren't
knock-on effects on the other person
because you know if you harass someone
that's a bad thing
um but it's this idea that you know so
the the men may have evolved in the
direction of over perceiving
um sexual interest just in case how does
female underperception bias tie in with
error management Theory so that's
um I mean there's this classic
distinction isn't there between uh men
prefer putting a greater emphasis on
physical attractiveness and sexual
access and women putting a greater
emphasis on resources and status and so
the female equivalent is
um
uh the female equivalent actually is uh
commitment isn't it it's it's commitment
skeptic skeptical commitment bias I
think is is the name so it's when you're
in what you're quoting someone
um what men
don't want to miss out on is the sexual
access what women don't want to miss out
on is the commitment according to the
skeptical commitment bias so women are
more likely to make errors in judging
commitment from men to be lower than it
actually is
because if women say hey I'm with this
guy
I think he's committed to me and he
isn't
big issue
whereas if I I'm with this guy and he is
committed to me but I'm a little bit
skeptical about it okay I could make an
error and hurt his feelings a little bit
maybe he doubles down and proves himself
to me but that error is less costly to
me than the other way around so this
would be the uh woman playing hard to
get
making a man wait longer before she
texts back perhaps committing to demand
less quickly yeah in the in the sort of
coding like I'm using courting as if as
if we're in Victoria I like courting
let's bring that let's bring that back
so I've been thinking about Victorian
meeting this week for some strange
reason
um yeah so if we if it's in that sort of
setup of a relationship stage yeah but
you also get the um skeptical commitment
bias within relationships as well uh
because then it's almost like um
it's even more damaging if your partner
isn't committed to you and goes off and
and cheats and takes that commitment
away so parental investment
oh that's the next one so parental
investment is like the granddaddy of all
theories right so for me it's it's one
of the key underpinning
theories of my thesis
um it's this
theory that crosses species in general
so it's not just specific to humans so
it's the idea that the sex that invests
the most
is the one that's in demand so it kind
of sets up these Market forces and this
really started with the Bateman
principle so that's actually looking at
sex cells so if you compare sex cells
you know guys generate millions and
millions and millions of sperm
continuously on the hour every hour
whereas women are born with all of the
egg cells that they'll ever have and
they're larger and they're fewer in
number so even at the sex cell level it
sets up this this imbalance where
um guys are providing something that's
quick and cheap whereas women are
providing something that's precious and
I've seen men and women there but of
course mammals in general follow that
pattern as well which is why we tend to
find sex differences in um mammals and
other species that are in kind of
predictable directions with men men
males doing the competing and females
doing the choosing now where humans are
different of course is
you have something called obligatory
parental investment so there's the the
stuff that you have to invest which for
most females isn't just the egg it's the
gestation it's the weaning you know this
this heavy obligatory investment whereas
males can generally have have sex and
leave so in most species that's an
option
um I'm not sure praying mantis or a
spider or something
um
the difference however is that in humans
obligatory parental investment isn't
just it we our typical levels of
parietal investment are much higher from
Men
so men do compare to other species
invest a lot in their offspring and
that's why the sex differences in humans
are actually quite modest compared to
other species like if you go to a zoo
and you look at gorillas and you or you
look at elephant seals and you look at
the marked massive degrees in physiology
between males and females you look at
humans it's it's not as as sharp so even
though there are sex differences there
because males invest so heavily in
Offspring
um it actually redresses the balance a
little bit making our sex differences
more moderate in size and parental
investment presumably as well is why
women are more choosy with
how many people they have sex with who
they have sex with the amount of work
that their partner has to go through
before they will do that
and well that's
that's the story I think because I've
I've heard I've heard that point be made
before but what's what's missing with
that is this sexual strategy sexual
strategies overlay of understanding the
distinction between short-term and long
term
um because you know women will really
really really
um
put the apply the standards to a
short-term meeting partner because what
are they getting out of the arrangement
they're they're getting the sex and
potentially falling pregnant for someone
who may not hang around
um when it comes to long-term meeting
though men are as choosy as women right
so it's not the case that we go on dates
where men get all dressed up in
three-piece suits and women go in their
dressing gowns and whatever they feel
comfortable in right so so women make an
effort as well as guys and that's
because they're two investors at the
table two potential investors
um so it yeah you've got to have that
Nuance about it as well within a
long-term setting yeah maybe there's a
little bit more pickiness on women but
but guys are picky picky as well if
they're going to invest
you know 20 30 Years bring up children
with a person then they want to know
they're getting a good deal as well
right when you talk about sexual
strategies are those the primary ones
short-term mating long-term mating
pretty much so there's been there has
been some work
um trying to see whether there's a
difference between your long-term
committed cohabiting marriage long-term
strategy
so that's what well established your
short-term strategy your one-night stand
your friends with benefits your your
promiscuity there have been some studies
that have tried to look at this Middle
Ground
but every time they do it it just seems
to fall into into short-term strategies
so it's like oh you've got a guy a guy
that you're with for now but you never
see it going out anywhere in the in the
future so you you can see yourself being
with them for the next three months but
not the next three years really it it
falls back into short-term strategy
um the vast majority of the time so I
say yes I say you really have these
these two constructs you're either
playing the short term game or the long
term they interact sometimes so a lot of
people are using a short-term strategy
with the idea that
um they want to transition that into a a
long-term thing uh so there's some uh
some overlap there but broadly speaking
I I see those those two strategies
that is the mate switching hypothesis or
at least it would be part of a female's
plan toward mate switching that it seems
like a good portion of infidelity from
women is
done as a monkey branching strategy to
move from one relationship to the next
this was moving from Dual mating
hypothesis to mate switching hypothesis
yeah I think you were talking about Alex
uh to Alex about that a couple of times
ago so I I I had a thought about that
earlier on today I can't remember what
it was yeah I I mean traditionally
even outside of relationships that's a
tactic as well right so nowadays it's
much more common have a short-term
relationship with someone first and then
if I really like them transition that
into a long-term relationship
um the thing about mate switching as
well is that guys do it too
um I think the difference however is
when you consider and this is one of the
biggest psychological sex differences
out there which is is the the desire for
casual sex sociosexuality so social
sexual desire has an effect size of 0.8
something like that which is quite large
by psychological terms so the difference
is that when men are having
um say an affair
it may well be just to have sexual
access and with no intention of moving
past that but women having lower
sociosexuality it's more likely that if
they cheat it's probably to pursue
long-term interests uh it's not to say
that men don't do it but that's where I
think that particular sort of
observation has come from Alex tweeted
that promiscuity seems to be a little
bit heritable does that suggest that
socio-sexuality is also heritable my I
haven't done a study on it myself but
I'm pretty sure it is I'm pretty sure I
I read it I mean the the basic starting
point for heritability is 0.5 anyway so
if you just guess 0.5 for anything
you'll be right in the vast majority of
the time but I'm pretty sure the
sociosexuality is heritable yeah that's
interesting so the implication there
would be uh if you are looking for a
particularly committed partner look at
whether his father has got five wives
continuously and yeah it's a very
uncomfortable thing for some people but
you know it always comes down to to that
if you want to have intelligent kids
have sex with an intelligent person yeah
dudes you know Robert Plummer's been on
the show and in Blueprint he says uh
genetics isn't everything but it's more
than everything else put together
uh like the most important thing that
you want to do if you want to have a
successful happy flourishing child is
pick the person that you have them with
very carefully yeah and the other one I
mean that's the one part of it and then
the other part is is the experiences
they have outside of the the family home
I mean if you take
um juvenile uh misconduct for example
and look at the sort of Ace models
behind that it's like 50 heritable and
then it's like 35 influence outside of
the home in fact I think it's like 40
and it's a tiny Slither in the home
which I always think is tragic because
there's enough pressure on young mums
these days or if you haven't bought the
right toy then your kid isn't going to
to develop the ability to see color and
and know what crackling textures are
it's like no feed the kids love the kids
but get them good friends yeah I mean
that's the I think the this is another
Rob Henderson thing that one of the best
predictors of future wealth is not the
wealth of your parents but it's the
average wealth of the postcode that you
grow up in
yes yeah
so you almost have this uh it's almost
kind of like a weird Lily Pad effect
surrogacy right yeah the next door
neighbor's father that is a really cool
musician but your dad's lame he's a
rocket scientist but he's sort of lame
because he's the guy that tells me that
I've got to go to bed at night but John
next door John's dad he's really cool
because he plays the guitar and I want
to learn to play the guitar and dude I I
think that there's a lot I see it in my
own life I see the influences of the
people that were around me even into
adulthood man like you know being a club
promoter for so long and and spending
time uh partying and being around people
and learning uh you know amazing
insights around human nature around
networking business launching
advertising marketing all of this stuff
but the social
um values that I had the hierarchy of
things that I prioritized were
completely skewed to how they are now
and now I'm spending like I'm on the
phone to David Buss for 90 minutes this
morning talking about stuff and he's
like telling me about you know his
daughter his dog needs to come over
because it needs to be petted like I'm
I'm I'm evidently going to have like a
different value stack now and you wonder
I always wondered about this you know at
what point do do our sort of values get
locked in and I'm kind of waiting there
certainly seem to be less fluid they're
less fluid than they were when I was 10
or 15 presumably but the influence of
the people around you is always going to
be there and I I
I do think that that's something that I
wish was in more parenting books
um yeah behavioral genetics should be in
more parenting books although if you're
if you're reading a parenting book
reading about behavioral genetics it's
probably a little bit late
um but also
what is the you know go to Every you you
want your kid to start boxing because
you don't even get beat up school okay
go to every different Boxing Club and
look at every kid that's in there yeah
yeah it's like when I go to a restaurant
and I look at the wine list I do that
that that usual thing if I don't pick
the cheapest I pick the second cheapest
right I must I'm I'm the sucker that
they they put the price up on the second
cheapest bottle but that's that's what
you want for any trait in your life
right so you want to be surrounded by
friends who are part of a wine list and
you want to be second from the bottom so
you want a lot of your friends if you
want to be rich you want a lot of your
friends to be richer than you if you
want to you know have uh make
connections you want to surround
yourself with people who are connected
because you will learn from them and you
will grow with them as long as you're
liked being I I think that's one thing
that should go in parent parenting books
that is is very non-pc we don't have
enough conversations about how it's
important to be liked not loved yep but
just liked just tolerated just like
people people quite happy to be around
you but I think the more you the people
you surround yourself with absolutely so
it's so important but that's not just a
childhood thing yeah through your whole
life that's one of Peterson's rules is
uh don't allow your children to do
anything that makes you hate them yeah
and you want the child to walk into the
room and for the parents in there to
give them a big hug and pick them up and
ask them how everything's been going in
school you don't want because the kids
will pick up on it if they're like oh
God Andrew's coming around again I hope
she doesn't bring that Power Ranger
flashbacks yeah
it was that guy I was a very unlikable
child so yeah no no and when I when I
read that in uh in Jordan's book that
that was one of the the slices of stuff
that Jordan says that makes perfect
sense to me before then talking about
chaos and then I switch off a little bit
um but that that's like everyone right
everyone's uh no one's black and white
everyone's a weird mixture of Gray
strategic pluralism yes strategic plural
that's the last of the five I think so
this is
um so if sexual strategies is about
having long-term and short-term
strategies distinct we call sets of
psychological mechanisms
strategic pluralism for me is how you
navigate switching between those
strategies you know some people are born
wanting a husband or a wife and they'll
do that they'll have a high school
sweetheart who becomes the only person
I'll ever sleep with and they'll have a
million kids with them and and die in a
rocking chair age 80. and good for them
so they're like hardcore long term and
then you have some people who never
settle down because they can't think of
anything worse and they just want to
have fun and have as much sex as
possible I know plenty of those people
as well but not everyone has that sort
of pure strategy lens and this isn't
something by the way that's just unique
to humans so a lot of animals uh from
squirrels to Bears to all sorts of weird
and wonderful things like I think 50 of
my my PhD thesis was animal studies on
on strategies
um most people will flick most people
will have a mixed strategy I will apply
short term and I'll apply long term so
strategic pluralism is about what when
do you switch and why
so for example if you are in a situation
or an environment which is mildly
dangerous
then you're probably going to move
towards uh long-term mating because it's
a safer environment to bring up a child
having the support of another person
if you're in a really really safe
environment one with a lot of social
support maybe good social welfare then
actually having that second partner
or having that at the partner to bring
up a child with doesn't add benefits and
so then short-term relationships are on
the cards
what's super interesting about that by
the way though is that's like a U-shaped
curve so you actually get some
situations which are so dangerous that
it's like all better off there's no
point in having parental care because
it's not going to make a difference so
actually some of the most sort of
um terrible situations you can find
people in uh people just sort of go into
end of the world promiscuous mating mode
wow that's so interesting yeah I um was
it I think it was Armageddon where
there's that famous scene where where
the girl says I don't want to die a
virgin and they like cut to the dudes
that she's saying it to his face and
he's like yes
unless Bruce Willis can fix it but yeah
it's um I mean that stuff I find that
stuff almost almost endlessly
um fascinating to think about how
different mating strategies can be can
adjust to the local ecology I remember
the first time that I learned about the
sex ratio hypothesis and it made me
think about humans like plants you know
you put a plant in the corner of the
room and there's a bit of light in the
top corner and the plant responds to the
local environment its ecology determines
the way that it's going to behave and
you know
sex ratio is just
literally endlessly interesting and I
imagine that strategic pluralism and sex
ratio kind of aren't exactly a million
miles apart from each other yeah so that
would be an example of a cue and we know
that sex ratio cues
um I think Anarchy did some some work on
this sex ratio cues can
um temporarily change short to mating
inclination what's super interesting
about it actually is that when you get
down to smaller species like arthropods
and stuff that are doing different
mating strategies because they have
short Generations you can actually run
the maths on what happens based on the
strategies they're following and you
actually find that the different sexual
strategies kind of balance out in terms
of Fitness in the long run so the the
ones that are employing sort of more
short-term strategies versus long-term
strategies you know 10 20 Generations
down the line
they're both representing an equal
proportion of the gene pool
um so they kind of have a way of
balancing out which is why we keep both
of them so they can both be successful
it's not like there's a single
optimizing function here now I mean some
some of it is context dependent of
course but yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
didn't you recently do a study
that mediated short-term mating desire
amongst men
based on their arousal
yeah yeah so yeah so I did that with um
Wiseman recently or wisman
um that was really really cool because
it was one of those things where the
effect was so reliable that and you just
couldn't explain it away with trait
variables so it was like yes if you get
guys horny they then say oh I I have a
greater interest in short-term mating
and that's one of those studies where
like people reply to it say oh yeah of
course well you've just done a study
showing that water's wet and I'm like
well hang on a second okay so yeah it
makes sense to you but if you had
someone who was very inclined towards
long-term mating so say we had our Mr
high school sweetheart thing
wouldn't you expect him if he was horny
to just think of his wife
and want sex and pursue sex with his
wife
you know if we're suspending what we
know
from sort of folk psychology for a
second like that's a plausible that's a
plausible hypothesis but that's not what
happens even he so if even when you
control for sociosexuality when you
control for dark Triad sexual arousal
leads to increase in short-term meeting
interest and I think that's really
really cool it's cool for lots of
different reasons you can go talk about
you know how that factors into
harassment and all sorts
um but just from a
um
just from having control over your own
mating Destiny perspective like you're
going to make different amazing
decisions based on whether you're horny
or not that's something you should know
yes if you
what was what was I can't remember what
it's something that rhymes it's like
ejaculate before you evaluate or
something like that uh that's just like
a little piece of advice to guys before
they perhaps consider going in you know
that they're in a long-term relationship
with a committed partner and one evening
maybe they've bumped into some girl and
he goes home and she finds him on
Instagram and then messages him and
stuff and it's like oh should I should I
go around and go well
you might just be horny you might you
might be able to fix this
a lot more easily than something that's
a bit more of a permanent decision uh
but yeah I mean the the Insight of the
reverse what what does it suggest to you
then
that horniness increases short-term
mating what does that say
what like why would that be location
why would that be the case
um
really
stepped back and thought about it from
an adaption perspective I've been
thinking more about
see the thing is I've got this whole
other arm of my research about sexual
harassment that I'm doing at the moment
you see and sociosexuality turns out to
be like a big big predictor of sexual
harassment Behavior so I've kind of
approached this from from that
perspective of if it's activating
short-term mating what implications
might it have uh have for that but I
think it's a case of
it all right okay yeah well it comes it
comes down to mismatch you can see the
cogs actually turning in my head
and those are outside of the Academia
right now why not I should have brought
a whiskey with me
um the thing is because it it's kind of
like the voyeurism thing that I've done
as well right because I've done some
work on voyeurism because again with
sociosexuality that tends to predict for
your voyeuristic Tendencies tends to be
higher than men why well generally
speaking if you're seeing something
that's getting you sexually aroused
that's historically
um and ancestrally a pretty good
indicator that some sex is to be had
you know so there is no equivalent in
the Stone Age apart from perhaps a cave
painting on a wall of a pornographic
video I mean I was you know I've said
this to the students the other day it's
like it it's if you think about how
ludicrous it is that there's a 2D image
in front of you that you can put your
hand on that you can look around the
side of a monitor and it's clearly not
real but it's enough to trick our
ancestral mating systems into thinking
that they're it's a giant sex cue sex is
about to happen enough to arouse us
you know so of course your psychology is
going to be line lined up with that sex
is available
I am now aroused I want the sex
I don't want to entertain a long-term
relationship with an extended quoting
process before I have it
[Laughter]
what how are you tying this into uh
sexual harassment do you think uh should
we have a should we extend a particular
amount of sympathy to uh men who have
got highly heritable they didn't choose
it socio-sexuality and these are people
who's over perception bias is just
running rampant
so there's a couple of different flavors
of sexual harassment let's call it right
so there are some guys out there
who are just flat out predators
I've met them I've seen them in
nightclubs I've kicked them out of
nightclubs because they go and they find
the drunk woman and their stone cold
sober and they hunt and they walk around
and they pretend to dance with their
friend and they try to isolate like
there are some proper Predators out
there and that is one flavor of
harassment and and the really really
serious serious stuff
you then also have harassment that in my
view is born from
misunderstanding
yeah so not guys going out of their way
to cause harm and to cause pain and one
of the fundamental uh misunderstandings
is that people apply what they want
to the mind of the other person so
humans are really really good at theory
of mind it's like one of the human
superpowers that we really take for
granted being able to to guess and put
what other people think put our mind in
theirs human superpower
but it has its limitations and one of
its limitations and one of the reasons
that sociosexuality is one of the
biggest predictors of harassment is
because if someone is playing the
short-term Mating Game they make an
assumption that the other person is as
well
so if you're playing a short and this
isn't just Men by the way this is this
is women too so women who have high
social sexuality are going to assume if
they're heterosexual that men too have
high sociosexuality of course the
statistics will show that they'll be
more right in that guess than the other
way around
um and so if you're playing short-term
strategy
short-term relationships are about sex
that is the the main part of it it's not
like a long-term relationship you strip
away the courting process you strip away
the commitment the getting to know a
person it's about having sex and it's
about having sex as quickly as possible
and so those are high sociosexuality
they're more likely to initiate physical
contact they're more likely to lead the
conversation down a sexual route more
quickly
um and make no bones about it some
people are doing that because they know
it'll make someone uncomfortable but
they're just playing the numbers game
but others are doing it because they
genuinely just think the other person
wants that and are causing
clumsily causing harm distress and upset
are you familiar with this uh new
performative
um like resistance to sex study that's
just come out so this was I mean William
sent this to me and this is the sort of
thing where I talk about everything on
my newsletter right anything I'm like
any study that's just come out I'm ready
to go this is one that as of yet is a
little bit too spicy so I'll read you
the abstract okay okay we investigated
whether women ever engage in token
resistance to sex saying no but meaning
yes and if they do what Their reasons
are for doing so a questionnaire
administered to 610 undergraduate women
asked whether they had ever engaged in
token resistance and if so ask them to
rate the importance of 26 possible
reasons we found that 39.3 percent of
the women had engaged in token
resistance on at least once their
reasons fell into three categories
practical inhibition related and
manipulative reasons women's gender
roles attitudes
arotophobia erotophilia and other
attitudes and beliefs varied as a
function of their experience with token
resistance their sexual experience we
argue that given today's sexual double
standard token resistance may be a
rational Behavior it could however have
negative consequences including
discouraging honest communication
perpetuating restrictive gender
stereotypes and if men learn to
disregard women's refusals increasing
the incidence of rape
okay so now I know why uh Mutual Irish
friend kept that from me because he was
probably trying to not hurt my feelings
um because my lab has done something
similar and we haven't written it up yet
and actually we found a similar thing
with four with that 40 number
um only we didn't go for the token
sexual resistance route we just played
went for the playing hard to get route
so to to what extent have people played
hard to get to what extent did they
think other people play hard to get
because that's part of it as well
um it does have a different flavor to it
than sexual resistance but the one thing
um that we've picked up on
is
because we've also done some qualitative
focus groups on it it's something that
doesn't happen at the start of a
relationship so it doesn't happen at
that time zero you're meeting someone
for the first time asking them out on a
date it happens a little while in in
that quoting process when you've been on
a couple of dates and you're sort of
like maybe trying to communicate that
your make value is higher than it is or
you're starting to play games with
someone that you're genuinely interested
in
at that stage you actually get a large
proportion of so so the the proportion
of women saying that they've ever done
that as a tactic and guys because
there's not really a sex difference
there is like 70 80 percent
and actually
um if you ask women uh you know if they
met someone that they you know for the
first time that they really liked uh
what are the chances that they would use
playing hard to get as a bit of a tactic
you know you get like 40 or something
like that but what's really really
interesting is that women overest sorry
women overestimate how often other women
play that tactic
um and Men actually underestimate how
often women play that tactic when I
thought it was going to be the other way
around me too yeah
um but I guess the issue with it is
because I think it is a natural part of
flirting playing playing hard to get
failing disinterest from both camps from
both males and females but I think that
if you're someone who is looking for a
short-term relationship so you're going
to be more sex focused anyway and you
think that you've noticed that women
play hard to get sometimes so obviously
I'm talking about men here for a second
and you think that they're inclined to
do it within the first 30 seconds of
meeting them
that's the recipe for disaster
because if you haven't actually objected
within the first 30 seconds your
presumption is that any maybe they are
it's performative as opposed to genuine
reticence yeah and so my lab's doing
quite a bit at the moment with um this
sort of predictors of luck pushing to
what extent you know you've asked
someone once they've already said no
um
you know the next day you see them again
if you were to ask them a second time
what do you think your chances are of
that being successful so we're doing
some some work on on that at the moment
so that luck pushing that maybe I'll try
again element because when you do the
male focus groups there really is that
that that thing of what if it doesn't
harm you may as well try again because
you never know
so there's obviously some stuff to do
there with educating around harm as well
absolutely I mean all of this is
mediated by being
Charming is the closest approximate word
that I can find for it and and
delivering whatever it is that you do
whether it's the cashier that smiles at
you as she packs your bags or whether
it's the workmate that said no yesterday
or whatever I do think that this is the
subject of John Berger's book uh make
the first move which is really really
great and and touches on sex ratios from
a very sort of pro-female perspective
Murray says that you know for almost all
of human history women were told that
the way to attract a guy was to treat
him like you don't like him why men love
[__] and you know faint disinterest
and all this sort of stuff but in a post
metoo World men are hyper sensitized to
being accused of being a creep or being
overbearing they absolutely do not want
to be any of the the issues I think it's
some huge majority of men would never
consider approaching a woman in a bar an
acceptable thing to do for fear coming
across as creepy even though 86 percent
of women still want a man to make the
first move and yet there's still a high
proportion of women who have been made
to feel creepy by guys when they've
approached them so you have all of these
kind of intersecting uh challenges that
you need to weave your way through uh
yeah absolutely and if you look at some
of the work that leaf canaire has done
or uh apostolo's done you know one of
the things that that people who are
perpetually single report is that
they're useless at flirting yeah so they
if you take a flirting index and ask
people you know how to rate themselves
on it they tend to do really because
flirting's a skill and it's it's a skill
that you have to learn you have to learn
how to
um read body language how to read behind
what people are saying to be sensitive
to the fact that actually we're not
flirting and I need to go away
um but unfortunately it is a skill it's
something that you're not born with and
it's something that you certainly don't
want your parents to teach you
um and you have to kind of develop that
so I think we're now reaching the point
where it's almost not okay
to learn that skill and that's a bit
problematic I think
I wonder
whether
part of the challenges that young guys
under the age of 30 are struggling with
that's causing sex listeners is
Downstream from
straight up poor social skills to the
point where their ability to flirt has
just been tuned down that it's not to do
with yep the the increasing female
achievement and the hypergamy and the
men not being able to be up and across
the
but also maybe this generation of men
are just worse flirters than any other
generation before I I absolutely think
that and I think you know
go back 30 40 50 years
that sort of stuff you'd be taught by
your older brother or by other positive
male role models that you have you know
there's this whole
issue around
people like Andrew Tate and stuff at the
moment where it's like well we've got
this vacuum and these people are
stepping into the vacuum and men are
seeking them out
and you've got to think well well what
is causing that vacuum what used to fill
that that isn't anymore and for me it's
strong male role models that are showing
not toxic masculinity but like good
masculinity
yeah so it's it's your scout Masters you
know I'm I'm not hugely religious but
it's your church leaders it's your
religious leaders you know it's
organizations like the Freemasons it's
it's
uncles coaches you know good good men
who were able to to show you what being
a good man means and I think now we're
just sort of just I mean I do it myself
you're just scrolling on your phone of
an evening doing nothing that's not
learning
positive how to contribute to society in
a positive way and young men so I used
to live right I used to live in the
middle of a park right I used to rent a
property in the middle of a park so I
used to see all of like the 8 9 10 11 12
year old kids uh and how they used to
sort of run around in the park during
the summer time that sounds so creepy
I'm not like that but anyway the point
is
half half the time they were destroying
things and not the young girls the young
men are destroying things they're
throwing bottles someone planted a tree
they ripped the tree out of the ground
and it's like when you see these guys
it's almost like they have this yearning
to control their environment with their
hands in some way
to actually do something to make some
sort of Mark
and it's like if you don't give an
opportunity to construct in some way
they'll just destruct yes
and I think that that's part of the
problem as well that you we we need
stronger male role models who are
helping young men giving giving them
some some way of building their status
um because that's a whole other argument
as well of how do you build status
because you have this really nice
dichotomy in a lot of traditional
societies between Prestige and dominance
and I think these days a lot of young
men see it's dominance dominance
dominance that's how you build status
when actually prestigious is more of a
sort of healthy way of building
um buildings as well it's more likable
it's definitely going to be able to
scale over time because you know your
dominance if you continue to play that
game eventually is going to get you
punched in the face or thrown in jail or
something bad is going to happen
Prestige may end up with you being
people being jealous of you but that's
significantly better than the outcomes
that you get from dominance yeah I am
I'm playing around with this idea at the
moment and unfortunately it it seems to
not really be uh actually holding much
weight but we'll see as I continue to do
more research the male sedation
hypothesis which is why have we not seen
young male syndrome given the incredibly
high levels of sexlessness amongst young
men very high levels of sexlessness but
not uh a
um in-kind increase in the destructive
anti-social behavior that you would see
amongst that particular cohort of guys
yeah and my theory originally was that
uh porn and video games are giving a
titrated dose of reproductive cues and
of status seeking camaraderie
goal-oriented Behavior but I'm yet to
see any evidence that suggests that porn
use
turns down men's desire for real world
sex David lay I couldn't find that
um he's he doesn't see any evidence for
it uh David bus sent me an article
earlier on this morning that also
doesn't seem to show that sexual desire
is mediated by porn what what's your
view on this every time I put Paul in it
doesn't predict anything
um you know and it's such a nice it's
amazing situation hypothesis
yeah it it's it's it's a very nice and
I'm sure that there's some other way
that we can uh find the menopause
sedated yes but um now every time we put
porn use in in like harassment stuff and
and that it doesn't it doesn't come up I
will tell you something interesting
though I'll tell you something
interesting from the polygyny pre-print
that we've got out now about that status
and that status thing The Prestige and
dominance so social sexuality
is positively associated with dominance
but negatively associated with Prestige
so there seems to be something there
about prestigious men being more
inclined for a long-term relationship
and dominance being more inclined for
that seems to make sense but what's
interesting is that it's going in the
opposite direction I can understand how
dominant men would be higher in
sociosexuality but if the if the arrow
is moving in the other direction that's
interesting
what was that uh attitudes of people in
the west to multi-partner relationships
yeah so that's a pre-print that I've got
out now uh it's a funny story I'll be
presenting that at hbest by the way
because you and me both there we go so
I'm on this uh consensual non-monogamy
uh panel which is is really interesting
because it's because I didn't set out
for this study to be a consensual
non-monogamy study and then it's it's
under review with archives at the moment
and it came back with three reviews all
saying we we love the methods we love
the results but we want you to
completely rewrite the introduction from
a consensual non-monogamy lens so I was
like right interesting let's crack on
with that so I pulled in Justin mcgilski
and he's um gonna help me with that
um anyway so this study was
we live in in the UK and in the UK
you're not allowed to do polygamy of any
kind so you're not allowed uh to marry a
man can't marry several wives a woman
can't marry several men it's called
bigamy it's still punishable by seven
years in in prison by the way
um so it's something that's socially
sanctioned and whereas you can you can
have relationships like that they're
generally frowned upon right which is
really really interesting because you
know the if you look at fossil evidence
and you look at our biology It All
Points towards at least a active
polygyny in in humans in some way so men
having
um a smaller number of men having uh
access to to more women rather than
everything being a monogamous pairing
and also if you look at all
hunter-gatherer societies
um I think something like 86 percent of
hunter-gatherer societies permit
polygyny not everyone tends to be the
chief and you know people who are very
high status in those societies
um but they're permitted in most
cultures that uh a current or uh that
we've previously known about that have
fallen apart so if there's an argument
to be made that maybe polygyny is
something that's hung around as part of
the human mating experience for some
time so we've run a study just basically
to see well do you actually find a
desire for polygeny
in a population I.E the UK where it's
actually
you know there's sanctions against it
um because if you can still find
interest in that mating arrangement in a
society where you know people aren't
talking about it you're not allowed to
do it or maybe that's telling you that
we've we've got an a part of our uh
evolved meeting psychology is uh is
still there kind of in the in the
background so that's what we did we
basically asked a rear well two studies
actually a large sample of men and women
about their poligenous interest and
polyandry which is the multiple men to
women
and what happened
interesting stuff really interesting
stuff so
um I forgot I've got the exact figures
here because I haven't committed them to
Memory yet so we did quite a few things
in terms of like correlational profiles
and comparing
um interest for polygenous relationships
against for example just having an
effect Fair partners and stuff but
basically what you find is a third of
guys say that they would be open to a
poligenous relationship so a third of
guys say yes I would like to have two
long-term Partners at the same time who
know about each other accept each other
they don't get to have sex with anyone
else just me
and a third of them are like yes I would
be open to that
women being part of that relationship
not so much about one in 20 were saying
yes I would be like a co- girlfriend or
a co-wife
um and then quite a bit of a proportion
that's unsure so about 20 20 of guys are
unsure 14 of women are unsure so
sometimes it's easier just to look at
the nose so 50 of guys are like
definitely no 80 of women are like
definitely no are you surprised at 50 of
men saying definitely no given male
desire for sexual variety
um I'm not surprised because of
when you start looking into polygyny
just how difficult that is to juggle as
a relationship
um but also remember this is in a
background where people are brought up
to be told that this is wrong
so it's actually more the the other way
around I'm surprised that you've got 50
of men who are saying either yes or or
uncertain
um but what's really interesting is that
you get that big sex difference in
polygyny so women are like no no no no
no
um guys are like yeah okay I'd be open
for it but when you look at polyandry
the Sexes respond pretty much the same
which is that about 10 percent of people
say yes
um about 10 to 20 of people say that are
unsure but most people are saying no and
there's not a big sex difference between
men and women there so the the
um there's a much more drive on the the
guy's side towards uh polygeny then
women towards polyandry but it's about
the same number of men that would accept
being part of a female's Harem as women
who would want to hire him of men around
about ten percent that's a so much
better way of putting it I should have
had you on the paper summarizing stuff
for me uh as as you may be aware I'm
actually giving a short 15-minute
presentation at H best this year so
really I should go to that yeah yeah I
can get you an invite bro you speak to
me I'll probably be able to sort you out
um
so interesting stuff there around
stated and revealed preferences
uh oh absolutely absolutely because I
actually I I put that in the paper right
so there's a massive difference between
like would would guys actually like once
you've got the decision this there's
that whole whole hot and cold reasoning
element to it as well right
um sorry I interrupted not just that was
it it was just the stated and revealed
preferences thing I mean you know guys I
imagine that
uh actually do I I was thinking about
the fact that if a man was offered the
the multiple women in front of him that
it would it would sound great but I
think that that really works best for
short-term mating I think when you
actually are faced with the
Stark thermodynamics of trying to
have a household with two women who as
much as they say that they get on grade
and maybe in the bedroom they're
fantastic I mean we've had a lot of
history of intra-sexual competition
between women
poisoning each other's kids poisoning
each other trying to push them down
Cliffs you know all manner of [__]
that's gone on and it wouldn't surprise
me if
men
may be mediated by status
yeah oh absolutely and when we
um when you look at the data in more
traditional societies you basically find
that women are drawn towards polygyny
only when the benefits they can get out
of the polygenous marriage exceed what
they could get out of a monogamous
marriage so if I've got a husband who
can only invest five
um
all in me or there's another husband
here who can invest 20 in me and another
person well then I'm getting 10 of the
20 which is more than the five so
there's a there's a balance there of
would I be would I be better off on my
own or part of part of this thing in in
terms of having my utilitarian
calculation in that regard yeah it is
and it's also uh I mean a lot of these
societies tend to have a lot of control
over women as well so it's it's like the
the way that women actually uh you know
if they have less the way that they do
things and gain access to things is a
lot of the time through men
um which is a shame I learned I can't
remember what I was listening to
yesterday but I learned about how the
culture of Chinese feet tying oh man I
hate that stuff have you seen the
pictures no thanks oh not good it's all
it's well uh cultural cultural relatives
the culture of relativism should we
judge yeah I'll judge you see they look
like Pig strutters it's awful the the
toes get curled around it's isn't there
a argument that the reason that that
came about was due to Asian Warlords
that had huge harems of women and didn't
want the women to be able to run away
I have absolutely no idea I'll find the
segment and I'll send it to you uh but
basically the argument and the same was
for female genital mutilation that if
women don't enjoy sex and or can't run
away that there is less chance of a very
inherently unstable Harem of like an
unsustainable number of women uh
crashing and burning around you because
why would they sleep with the the hot
guards kingsguard that works outside the
door or why would they run away from
this terrible situation if they either
can't run or don't enjoy sex yeah it's
it's I mean I the the Chinese foot
binding thing my understanding was that
that was to deal with like a small feat
being more feminine and petite the
female genital mutilation or especially
when you get like the there's a couple
of stages to it and when you get to like
the worst one there's there's absolutely
nowhere nothing that you can no way you
can interpret that apart from male
control it's it's [__] disgusting
um and what's really bad about that is a
lot of the time there's this sort of
cultural attachment to it where it's
other women pushing for it as well so it
almost like started as a male thing and
then it's like then what do you think's
going on there intersexual competition
again no because it tends it can
sometimes be like mothers and stuff like
that as well straight up culture
artifact straight up like oh this is you
know this is part of being a woman and
and oh it's I mean I'm out in Austin
Texas at the moment and the number of
times that me and William will be sat
around the dinner table talking to a
bunch of our lad mates and the topic of
foreskins will come up because that's
obviously our favorite conversation to
have when we're saying of course yes yes
especially what men talk about if it's
beef jerky we immediately want to talk
about about foreskins and uh brilliant
that's exactly the same when you hear
secular non-jewish you know grew up in a
a totally secular household guys who
will say yeah my dad's circumcised I'm
circumcised I'll be circumcising my son
but okay why that's interesting why
what's your reason yeah well it's just
you know everyone's that's how
everyone's got it I'm like well it's um
it's another level though Chris the the
female gentle gentleman selection oh
yeah it's it's it's really something
else it's to me it's the equivalent of
saying am I gonna some Nails pulled out
or am I gonna have my hand chopped off
with the nails being pulled out being
the circumcision it's really yeah not
good it's it's it's not good it's it's
the type of thing which really makes my
blood boil if I'm honest when I've read
about it and stuff oh so move on uh how
hooray okay how many previous sexual
partners is too many
212.
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh no oh sorry you I thought you were
asking me about my own personal Craft
um right so I did some work with Steve
on this and you're gonna really enjoy
this because we've got a follow-up study
that I'm just writing up at the moment
so we did this study in 2018 I think
2017-2018. it actually so this is one of
my claim to fame this got written up in
Playboy so so that's like you know oh
we've made it
um
so we basically said you know for a
long-term partner here's a person
they're generally attractive how willing
would you be to go on a date with them
or entertain them as a long-term partner
based on what people now call body count
but when we did the research was just
having sexual partners they've had and
you I still remember walking into
Steve's office and him having on the
screen where he'd plotted up the data
he's got the the nicest curve ever and
he was like yeah I'm writing this up
it's a lovely lovely curve and it
basically Peaks at around about four
being like the optimal uh three to four
what's really really cool is it's not
just a linear pattern so it's not like
three to four and then it just goes
downhill you get this little curve so
people are a bit wary about a virgin as
well
uh it's still high so being a virgin is
I think equivalent to something like
having 12 Partners something like that
um yeah being of oh no it's less than
that it's seven to eight Partners is the
equivalent of kind of being a virgin is
this male to female female to male is
there agenda a sexed difference here
this it depends on uh again sexual
strategy so if you're just looking at a
long-term relationship the lines are so
close together you could squint and they
look the same where you get the
difference is for a short-term partner
and then men's standards drop
um compared to women but for a long for
a long-term partner no the nice sort of
curve shape is about the same how
different is a woman's short-term and
long-term curve
uh it's a little bit flatter
um so if they're looking for a
short-term relationship whether someone
has two partners or like 12 Partners
it's
pretty similar right it's pretty similar
so it flattens out a little bit the
curve is sort of less steep but it's
still much higher than guys
what do you think that it says that
having uh a virgin or somebody with one
partner is less desirable than somebody
with three or four is this stated in
revealed preferences again or is there
something else going on I think that
this is
so you've got to think it's all it's a
U-shaped curve at the end of the day and
there's almost like you you shape uh
u-shaped risks associated with so risks
on either end so the risk to having
someone with zero sexual partners is
that there might be a reason for it
there might be a reason that they're a
virgin
so it could be that they're just not a
good deal it could be that they have low
mate values so it could be that you're
actually
completely overestimating how good a
catch this person is
yeah once you enter into a relationship
and you start investing you don't want
to be investing in someone who is not
the best deal for you on the other end
when you have people have too many
sexual partners then you have things
like sexually transmitted disease if you
want a long-term relationship the
chances of them may be cheating on you
or leaving is is probably is probably
quite a bit higher
um and so there's risks all round but
the higher number I believe associated
with different risks than the lower
numbers
but interesting I'm doing a follow-up
study so this one was in uh the Journal
of sex research and it was just on a UK
sample
um so I thought right how can we just
like inject some steroids into this
thing so I've redone it
but we've done it with 10 countries so
UK Poland Norway Japan
Brazil all over the place yeah
um and not only are we now looking at
numbers but we're looking at when the
numbers were
because what I realized is that if
you're asking people about 12 partners
and they may they can make a judgment
but then if you were to say it's 12
partners and 11 of those have been in
the last three months
that's very different to 11 of them were
around about when that person was 18 19
and 20 and then recently they've only
had one or two gee so I mean numbers the
same but if you were going to pick
someone for a long-term relationship
that's going to commit to you and you
might get married to and have kids too
which one are you going for there's
someone who clearly was a bit sexually
desirable in their youth and has calmed
down a bit or someone who's actually
pretty active now they're on a tear at
the moment uh yeah absolutely so um yeah
so we've got that I'm just plotting up
the data at the moment isn't it
interesting that some of the common
men's advice on the internet especially
around pre-selection uh you know there's
a big push at the moment for the
polygyny thing that most girls will
happily take a high value man if you
know he's sufficiently high value and
she'll happily share him and so on and
so forth
that doesn't seem to be borne out in
this data given the fact that men's
preference for partners especially over
the long term and women's doesn't
diverge all that much now it doesn't
seem like women because they're already
count in a man as being a some sort of
pre-selection uh attractor
and there's there's some work I'm doing
at the moment I keep saying this I've
got more studies than I have time to
write the map and I'm doing some work
with um Leaf canaire at the moment about
the sexual double standards because you
you almost have sexual double standards
at a global level and a personal level
so the global level is like or the
societal level is what do you think
society says
um and that's when you sort of get
narratives like well
um girls don't care about a guy's body
count but guys care about a girl's body
count the sort of societal level
but whenever you measure it at the
personal level so what an individual
actually thinks
very little evidence for the sexual
double standard
so it's one of these things where we
actually think it's a thing but when you
actually talk to someone it turns out
not really to be a thing what do you
think that says about our own sexuality
in the way that we perceive other
people's
I think that it's it says that sometimes
our uh mating theory of mind can be
quite faulty
um I think that there's
culture wars all over the shop including
between men and women these days and I
think it ends up in a place where the
Sexes become quite caricatured
especially based on maybe the most
extreme examples
um so again one of the most common one
is that people will apply short-term
mating psychology of men
to men so they will assume that the men
who are only after short-term
relationships and what they want they
will say all men are like that even
those who are looking for long-term
relationships
um and I I actually think a lot of
suffering in in the dating world comes
from
conflating short-term and long-term
mating desires so either you're after
something long-term
um but you're picking someone who's
after something short-term
that causes a lot of um confusion or
thinking that you want something
long-term when you actually want
something short term uh which I think is
also quite interesting the number of
people I've met who say that they want
to get married and have kids and settle
down but then you ask them what their
make preferences are and they just reel
you off all of the short-term mating
preferences and then of the long-term
mating preferences it's like well
actually it sounds like you just want a
short-term partner because you don't
care about kindness you don't care about
whether they want kids you don't care
about
um uh whether they can they're good
communicators or whether they can
empathize well you just care about do
they look good are they good in bed are
they going to give me resources now
um so yeah a lot of people are playing
the short-term game when they think
they're playing the long-term game I
wonder whether
that would be I wonder whether that
would have a sexed difference I would
imagine that given women not wanting to
seem easy not wanting to come across
like they are not valuing their body in
the same sort of way that you may find
that women will
use I'm after a long-term mate as
perhaps even their own self-deception in
order to perhaps pursue short-term
mating goals
I don't know it's just it's an
interesting so to round out that um
optimal number of Partners was it almost
exactly the same for men and women it
was about four
yeah
yeah I've got it here in front of me now
about four I mean this was three to four
this was a few years ago mine so we're
gonna see
um the we're going to see the difference
in the new study I mean
well one of the things that we have done
is we've looked at like four versus
twelve versus 36
um and the distribution patterns because
we show people actual physical
distribution patterns so here's one that
shows that it was recent
um distribute that four obviously is
still an optimal there's no effect
effective distribution for four so it
doesn't matter when people had Partners
four is like a nice solid number
um it's when you have the larger numbers
that's when it matters more of when when
did that happen is that something in
your past or not
um and once you actually send a load of
those into the past the difference
between say 4 12 and 36 start to
converge a little bit so it gets to the
point where the difference is become
minimal so that's quite interesting it
adds that extra dimension you conducted
an experiment where you asked chat GPT
about about
preferences before we get into that what
make preferences do people typically
look for in a partner
so
I I love the right okay so I'll give you
the the the the the real answer
everything right so if you give people a
likert scale one to nine and say what's
your ideal for humor intelligence
physical attractiveness Good Financial
prospects creativity they go nine eight
eight nine nine eight nine they just do
the whole thing which is why a lot of
the research we do we have to ask about
minimum make preferences in which case
they go uh seven seven seven seven seven
but actually the best research just then
introduce an element of force choice in
some way like a ranking task like okay
so everything's High what's the highest
and when you do ranking tasks the things
that appear at the top are like
Dependable character being kind and
understanding even though a lot of
evolutionary research is focused on the
sort of physical attractiveness Good
Financial prospects thing that actually
ends up a little bit further down in the
list most of the time but so a lot of
the the traits in the top are actually
things which are
um very useful for long-term
relationships so pleasing disposition is
my favorite one
um if you just if there wasn't a rich
history of this study I don't think
anyone would use the words pleasing
disposition but this ranking task of
like 18 traits or whatever they started
doing this in
um just after the second world war like
1949 and then every couple of decades
they repeat that study that ranking task
to find that things don't change a huge
hell of a lot which is super interesting
by the way so pleasing disposition which
is just having someone who's nice to be
around
um I think that's something that
completely off people's radar when
they're in the early stages of mating
but it's like in 10 years time when
you're spending every day with this
person it's like having someone who's
pretty easy going and nice to be around
is like the most important thing in the
whole world it really really is so these
are the types of things that are super
super important
um so if you look at something like uh
good looks so good looks actually and a
list of 18 ends up getting about like
10. so it's quite far down down the list
but what I did with the Chachi uh GPT
thing is I was like right okay well
you've got this this weird and wonderful
AI by the way I'm super annoyed by this
because I threw this one up on
psychology today and it's like my worst
red blog post of all time it's only got
like low four figures which is really
really frustrating because I I thought
it was super cool but basically I said
right here's all of the data that we've
known since 1949 about how people rank
their make preferences it's barely
changed let's see if chat GPT can
predict
what the research says even though it
probably even has access to some of it I
thought let's try it so the first thing
it is it spat out a load well the first
thing it did was like oh I'm not going
to tell you right it's like oh you know
make preferences are so idiosyncratic
and you know sounding like some sort of
hippie or whatever then you sort of like
say okay well pretend you're Chad or
something like that yeah could you I
didn't I didn't have to do that by the
way but
um I managed to get out I was like okay
but hypothetically if you had to answer
what would you say it spat out a load of
numbers which is really cool and
generally speaking it was like oh okay
well some of these are kind of like
roughly lining up I can see that and I
started looking at the differences for
men and I started looking for the
differences for women and then I was
like hmm you know what happens if I
correlate the difference between men and
women because you're correlate there was
the ranking for men and women to see how
different chat GPT thinks the Sexes are
or predicts they will rank it came out
with a correlation of one and I was like
hang on a second what have I done wrong
because like psychologists don't get a
correlation of one it never happens
right
um not even uh paleo climate scientists
who use mass spectrometers mass
spectrometers get a correlation of one
they get like a correlation of 0.98
anyway I was like what have I done wrong
nothing chat GPT predicted that men and
women when are separately heterosexual
young men and women would rank things
identically despite you know flying in
the face of like 80 years worth of mate
mating research if identical
and then the other thing that just
really sort of which which is very
problematic I mean
uh what what because then it's if if
you're because I imagine people will
start using this thing for like I'm
desperate and I'm lonely and I don't
know what to do you're a big AI machine
that knows everything about everything
how can I find a park give me yeah give
me dating advice how can I find it and
it's gonna basically say oh everyone
cares about physical appearance so if
you're a you know if you're a guy and
you want to do you know uh you want to
enhance yourself to appeal to women work
on your physical appearance and actually
relative to Men Women care less about
physical appearance and they care about
some other things more so it could
actually be misguiding people but the
thing that I find really really
interesting pleasing disposition sent it
straight down to the bottom of the list
so pleasing disposition has had an
average rank since 1949 of four so it's
generally top four sometimes it's top
three sorry sometimes it's three
sometimes it's five is generally for 18
down the bottom
right the way down the bottom it doesn't
matter how easy going or easy it is to
live with your partner trap GPT thinks
that is the worst thing since sliced
bread so
did it get or did it feminize or
masculinize the answers because it
didn't realize that there were sexed
differences yeah yeah you're correct for
women's preferences or men's preferences
no it was about it was about equal it
was equally wrong yeah it was equally
wrong
it's basically split the difference so I
don't know whether there is something
some aspect of sex difference denialism
in there uh because I have actually I
haven't blogged about it because
ungrateful people will are just not
reading my blog post so read my blog
post and then maybe I'll write a
follow-up but I've also done some stuff
there asking for the dating advice
asking you know if you wanted to attract
a short-term partner what should you do
if you want to attract a long-term part
of what should you do asking from the
perspective of a heterosexual young man
and heterosexual young woman and the
answers are uh
predictably kind of like PC so for short
term if you're like oh how do I attract
a short-term Pawn it's like I'll make
sure that you have good communication
about consent
and I'm there like
foreign
steps ahead like that's important like
don't get me wrong like it's important
to have consent but if you're telling
some you know some some guy who's
regularly on 4chan who you know I can't
remember the last time we went outside
of a house to see a woman and your
advice is ask for consent if you want a
short-term relationship it's not going
to build well for that guy if he walks
up to a cashier and says can we have sex
do I have your concern do I have your
concern yeah that's the best way to find
it at least you ask for consent so
first off I think the chat GPT thing is
so interesting because it's a language
learning model so what I've stopped
looking at chat GPT as especially for
the more sort of social
inferences like what you're talking
about here is less a uh benevolent deity
and more like a
cultural aggregator
um absolutely yeah yeah with with some
slight bias built into the system
because they were they were starting
giving it personality tests Right
started giving it political orientation
test and then they were somehow able to
go in and update it and make it more
balanced so there's definitely some some
priors in here uh to be adjusted
um but it certainly comes up with all of
these warnings about the the that's yeah
you know oh you've got to be careful
asking stuff about mating people or
individuals and stuff like that it's
like well yeah that's that's great but
that's not that's not excellent dating
advice necessarily you know if you want
if you want to like good dating device
advice is you haven't had a haircut or a
shave in 15 years maybe if you do that
you will look a bit more presentable
yeah well I I think that the the
aggregation of whatever the sort of
cultural milieu at the moment is would
include massive sex difference denial it
would include you know consent being one
of the the form of things again coming
from a very particular portion of the
culture very particular group of people
um what I am interested in though going
back to the make preferences thing
what do you think it says first off that
something so seemingly banal and
forgotten about as pleasing dispositions
something which can't be optimized for
on online dating and also something that
is very rarely discussed when it comes
to dating advice for men but also kind
of dating advice for women you know with
the the Advent of Boss [__] leaning
culture and independent woman and stuff
like that
um
what do you think it says that that
ranks so highly and yet isn't shown in
advice again is this is that wrong is it
wrong that people say they want a
pleasing disposition but it's it's no
use to them when it comes to the
revealed preferences of Attraction and
secondly what does it mean that make
preferences are so stable over time how
can it be the case that for the last
80 years make references seem to have
stayed the same yeah I mean I wouldn't
say they stayed the same identically but
they're they're enough
there's enough stability they're what
I'd like to call
um it's a term I've started threading
onto my research so Canon canalization
canalized so likely to develop
regardless of of sort of social input so
a highly canalized preference like
kindness means that no matter what
developmental
um environment you drop someone into a
preference for kindness is likely to
develop and emerge you would need some
pretty strong social engineering for
that to not happen so we're talking
about things being analyzed
um so that was the the second part of
your question I forgotten what the first
part was why is it that uh Pleasant
disposition is so highly rated and yet
isn't advised for online uh dating isn't
really something that you can
communicate online isn't given as advice
for either men or women yeah I is it
stated and revealed again does does a
pleasing disposition only work in a
survey and if you had a pleasing
position does it actually work to
attract a mate I think it so I I think
it does so I've got a another I've got
another study that I'm writing up where
I get all the time for this I don't know
I'm I'm upskilling and it's like the
therapy as well at the moment which is
eating about 20 of my time so all of
these papers will be coming out in 2030.
anyway we did we run some data analysis
Steve and I on some dating uh speed
dating data one of the things that came
out on it because people think are speed
dating physical attractiveness you know
the stuff that you can see immediately
you know what one of the biggest
psychological predictors that came out
of this study
um it was political tolerance
political tolerance was one of the
biggest predictors of speed dating
success so being opposite someone who
was easy going when it came to politics
and I actually see this as kind of
nested in a similar factor to pleasing
disposition so you've got someone who's
quite agreeable who's quite easy going
who's going to listen to your opinions
and not judge you and these are super
important things and I think it's a
tragedy that that we neglect talking
about them and neglect
um sort of coaching people about them
and why would you why would you coach
someone about pleasing this position
when the mating Market is set up in such
a way with the the first filter at the
moment is physical attractiveness
physical attractiveness is the first
hurdle and so you can't blame people for
pouring all of their time and effort uh
to get over that hurdle before they then
reveal other aspects about themselves
but this is why I keep coming back to
like my my biggest piece of advice is to
do something like speed dating because
if you do speed dating you at least get
a chance to be in front of someone
holistically so they get it maybe only
eight minutes but at least in that eight
minutes okay they see a physical
attractiveness but then they have to sit
there for seven more while you get a
quick quick attempt to show them how
tremendously funny you are and witty and
gentle and kind
um
so I always sort of recommend that and
plus when people go to an event like
that a physical event all parties have
already invested something small in
terms of their time so you know the the
advice isn't out there but maybe we can
change that you and I
um towards pushing people to do some
stuff that's more holistic than just
swiping away on something that allows
people to judge you based on one or two
criteria I'm a big proponent of doing
CrossFit if you want to pull
um CrossFit if you want to pull your
muscles definitely you need to take I
mean the CrossFit side of it is
secondary but everyone's wearing no
clothes everyone's into the same sort of
thing everyone does it eight times a
week uh there you go that's CrossFit
crossfits are good but I totally agree
that um don't need to hate the player
you can hate the game and the game at
the moment is predicated on physical
attraction first and foremost and the
point you just made there is actually a
perfect one of pick a context pick your
context if you want a long-term
relationship go to places where people
aren't going there for a short-term
relationship if you're trying to find a
marriage partner in the nightclub you
are then trying to find a needle in a
haystack among people who are who are
open for short-term relationships
did you know I mean whereas if you've
got go you know you want someone who for
a long-term relationship go to a book
club
go to a book club where you'll meet
someone who's nice and pleasant and
intelligent and wants to talk about sort
of intelligent things and you can get to
know them and be their friend there was
that study that came out recently that
showed something like you know a third
of of women were close friends with
their long-term Partners before
um
entering into a relationship with them
and another further 20 they were
somewhat friends with their uh uh future
husbands
circling the orbit
in one form or another yeah exactly it's
so it's got me thinking a lot about this
friend zone thing right so the friend
zone is not necessarily a bad thing
there's there's almost different
segments of the friend zone there's the
friend your friend I'm getting to know
you and you're still a possibility and
then there's the person I met on the bus
who was smelly and I I lump you with
that so you know I think people have
popularized the friend zone to the point
where it's bad to be a friend
when actually go about 50 60 years ago
that's how people were meeting each
other for lifelong bonds they were
friends first and met each other through
close friends did you see a video that
was virally doing the rounds about three
weeks ago and it was
1940s 1950s Australian women being asked
on the street what traits do you want in
a partner
no no I I didn't but as you said that I
was thinking of the other one of the
night of the same time in London with
the uh in the 70s as the woman going and
pinching the the the bottoms of the
businessmen and asking whether it was
okay and I've also see the Australia the
Australian one where they allowed women
in pubs for the first time and they had
all the grumpy old men saying that they
uh they didn't like that but no sorry I
haven't seen this one I haven't seen the
women in pubs thing either the one it's
just uh the the saying like I can't do
an Australian accent but they say you
know he must be nice it would be it
would be lovely if he was if it was if
it was if he was nice and kind and and
respectful and and you think well
[__] hell like how how Antiquated is
this
um and I wonder again how much of the
espoused mating preferences that girls
have women especially because it's
mostly them that do the on Street
interviews right because it's it's
mostly male channels that are doing this
and they say how much do you think that
a guy should earn and you get this these
sort of ridiculous answers from from
women especially on college campuses
first off they're being selected because
they're like [__] 18 and a half right
like they don't know anything so that's
why they don't know what 100 Grand is or
500 Grand if they're just picking a
number out of the air so what you're
actually testing for isn't mate
preferences what you're testing for is
how much they've absorbed and aggregated
just rumor and cultural sentiment that
they think is something that's good to
say and also who which self-respecting
girl really is going to say you know
like 30 grand 35 Grand like especially
if they're around a group of girls
who've all said 100 you don't want to be
the friend that's like oh yeah I'll take
the bloke that earned 30 grand after all
of your friends have said a lot so I
yeah I I really do wonder how much of it
is
online dating globalized sexual
Marketplace uh the sort of dissolving of
of traditional sexual Norms all of that
Downstream creating a situation in which
it is much more popular to talk about
the the looks the status the resources
and yet
everybody knows that those things have
zero predictive power when it comes to
long-term relationship success or
happiness it's stuff like psychological
stability conscientiousness secure
attachment Style
I mean there's there's a positive spin
that you can put on that as well Chris
which is you know to put my Pinker hat
on for for a second of you know
everything getting better which would be
that perhaps back in the 1950s in
Australia there were a lot of men who
were not very nice and kind maybe this
in uh these days it's more taken for
granted that men who are in
relationships are less likely to
you know because I mean don't get me
wrong like you know [__] bands still
exist who do awful things let's let's
you know put that as a preface but I
think if you look at all of the metrics
of of you you know uh domestic violence
and stuff they are on a downward
trajectory when you look over time
periods of like two three hundred years
so maybe there is something something
there of kindness is a given now so on
to the next thing who knows women don't
have to necessarily state or optimize
for this because there is less
uh there are fewer situations it is less
frequent that they would encounter a man
who wouldn't be kind and gentle and so
on and so forth uh I'd be very
interested to know it'd be very
difficult for you today I'm more social
support as well so I think like women
are more likely to talk about these sort
of things you know it's more
um when you reach out for help
tends to be there
um again I'm not I'm not saying that
this this is a problem that's been
solved or anything there's people in in
terrible streets there but when you take
when you're looking over the span of
decades when you're comparing what life
was like for a woman in the Victorian
era compared to 2023 it's a very
different place
Andrew let's leave it there mate I
absolutely adore all of the stuff that
you do where can people read your
articles and keep up to date with your
work
oh okay so my Twitter is a good one so
that's at Dr Thomas HG I also have at uh
dating Darwin which is the one
associated with my blog uh so you keep
an eye out on those because we'll be
advertising for a study if you if you're
listening and you happen to be an incel
we'll be advertising a study on there
soon uh that we're running
um and I also run a website called
psychostudies.com UK which is a Free
Directory where people can advertise the
psychology studies that they're doing so
I thought I'd just give a quick shout
out to that absolutely look mate I
really appreciate your work I will see
you at hbest later on this year and uh
thank you very much for today
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign